we have interesting new polls from the
last two days they are both terrible for
Donald Trump but I actually want to do a
little bit more of a deep dive and look
at the internals of one of these polls
so big picture to new polls Tuesday poll
from Harvard Harris says Biden is up 12
a poll from the New York Times today
says Joe Biden is up 14 which is
absolutely stunning but let's focus in
on some of the details of today's New
York Times poll in this poll Joe Biden
is up 50 to 36 that's a 14-point lead
you also have 14% of respondents under
the other category that includes people
planning to vote third party people that
are as yet undecided so you still have a
lot in that other category now there are
two particular areas that are really
hurting Donald Trump number one is his
response to coronavirus and number two
is Trump's handling of race relations 60
percent of the country believes Trump
has mishandled coronavirus that's
important because it is dramatically
higher than Trump's approval and it
shows us that there is a big net deficit
that Trump is experiencing thanks to his
absolutely disastrous handling of the
virus that includes among white voters
and men typically white voters and men
favor Trump even among white voters and
men there is significant dissatisfaction
with Trump's handling of coronavirus
then on race relations sixty-one percent
of voters say they disapprove of Trump's
handling of race only 33 percent
approved these are two of the most
one-sided areas where Trump is
underwater now a couple of other
interesting things from this poll
Democrats and Republicans right now
according to the New York Times poll
equally support their party's candidates
it is independents that are sort of
making the difference for Joe Biden so
take a look at this 85 percent of
Democrats say they're going to vote for
Joe Biden 85 percent of Republicans say
they're going to vote for Donald Trump
that's even there are actually more
Republicans nationally than Democrats so
in a sense that favors Donald Trump
but independents are leaning towards
Biden by a 21-point margin which is huge
and then also interesting the Trump
campaign has been pushing the idea that
Biden is too old to be President
remember Trump turned 74 about 10 days
ago Joe Biden's 77 as of right now 60%
of voters disagree that Joe Biden is too
old so we don't know what's going to
happen between now and November but the
key numbers I'm looking at are number
one an incumbent president polling only
36 percent four months before the
election is not good number two oh and
let me say a little bit more about that
in head-to-head re-election campaign so
when you've had a strong third party
candidate the numbers are different when
you really have a head-to-head matchup
for president the the worst-performing
incumbent president was John Adams who
got 39% of the vote in 1800 even the
wildly unpopular Herbert Hoover still
got 40% of the vote against FDR in 1932
I don't think Trump will be under 40 no
matter what but if Trump ends up with
anywhere close to where he's polling now
40 to 44 even 45% of the vote
this could be a historic defeat if we
actually go out and vote that's number
that's one metric that's important trump
polling in the 30s four months before
the election the other really important
metric is that Joe Biden is regularly
polling over 50% 50% or more in polls if
you look at polling at this point in
2016 Hillary Clinton was only
occasionally polling 50% and when she
was it really didn't go any higher than
51 52 Joe Biden is regularly polling 50%
or even more and the reason that matters
is that the undecided vote the unsure
vote the third party vote as you get
closer to Election Day it often will
consolidate or move towards the
incumbent in this case the incumbent is
Trump what matters about Biden regularly
being at 50
or more is that Biden doesn't need to
get any more support to win if we don't
get complacent and go out and vote we
could see the economy take up a little
bit if coronavirus gets under control
it's only a blow out in November if we
go out and vote and that's a real
question mark so now that we've looked
at all the polls what you should do is
go out there pretending as if every
single one of these polls says Trump is
winning by one right the idea the
mentality you should have is I don't
care what the polls are I need to act as
if my vote alone
could give a State to Joe Biden of
course it's not literally the case but
that's the attitude that we should have
and we'll continue following the polls
we'll continue following Trump's
internals among independents on
coronavirus on race relations but in the
end at the end of the day we all need to
say on November 3rd what would I be
doing right now if my vote could be the
vote that swings this election from
Trump to Biden oh I'd go out and vote
that's exactly what I'm going to do and
of course many of us will vote early
many of us will be voting absentee and
that just means we have the opportunity
to lock our vote in even sooner we don't
even have to wait until November third
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way to take control of your
health and get personalized care from
the comfort of your home it's a service
called steady MD they're one of our
sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician who
understands your health needs you have a
one-hour video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call each doctor at steady MD
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you you
get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about health
concerns send prescriptions to your home
or local pharmacy and anything they
can't do online they'll quickly set you
up with an in-person provider to do
things like blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays there are so many practical
advantages to using steady MD for
primary care and it's also so much more
affordable go to steady MD comm slash
Pakman to take the free quiz see which
doctor is right for you I took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor who
specializes in my particular health
needs in situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started just click the
link right underneath this video